this holiday season people around the
world will give and receive presents you
might even get a knitted sweater from a
knot but what if instead of saying
thanks before consigning it to the
closet the polite response expected from
you was to show up at her house in a
week with a better gift or to vote for
her in the town election or let her
adopt your firstborn child all of these
things might not sound so strange if you
are involved in a gift economy this
phrase might seem contradictory after
all isn't a gift given for free but in a
gift economy gifts given without
explicit conditions are used to foster a
system of social ties and obligations
while the market economies we know are
formed by relationships between the
things being traded a gift economy
consists of the relationships between
the people doing the trading gift
economies have existed throughout human
history the first studies of the concept
came from anthropologist bronislaw
malinowski and Marcel Mauss who
described the natives of the Trobriand
islands making dangerous canoe journeys
across miles of ocean to exchange shell
necklaces and armbands the items traded
through this process known as the Kula
ring have no practical use but derive
importance from their original owners
and carry an obligation to continue the
exchange other gift economies may
involve useful items such as the
potlatch feasts of the Pacific Northwest
where Chiefs compete for prestige by
giving away livestock and blankets we
might say that instead of accumulating
material wealth participants in a gift
economy use it to accumulate social
wealth
though some instances of gift economies
may resemble barter the difference is
that the original gift is given without
any preconditions or haggling instead
the social norm of reciprocity obligates
recipients to voluntarily return the
favor but the rules for how and when to
do so vary between cultures and the
return on a gift can take many forms a
powerful chief giving livestock to a
poor man may not expect goods in return
but gains social prestige at the debtors
expense and among the Toraja people of
Indonesia the status gained from gift
ceremonies even determines land
ownership the key is to keep the gift
cycle going with someone always indebted
to someone else repaying a gift
immediately or with something of exactly
equal value may be read as ending the
social relationship so our gift
economies exclusive to small-scale
societies outside the industrialized
world not quite for one thing even in
these cultures gift economies function
alongside a market system for other
exchanges and when we think about it
parts of our own societies work in
similar ways communal spaces such as
Burning Man operate as a mix of barter
and a gift economy where selling things
for money is strictly taboo in art and
technology gift economies are emerging
as an alternative to intellectual
property where artists musicians and
open-source developers distribute their
creative works not for financial profit
but to raise their social profile or
establish their community role and even
potluck dinners and holiday gift
traditions involve some degree of
reciprocity in social norms we might
wonder if a gift is truly a gift if it
comes with obligations or involve some
social payoff but this is missing the
point our idea of a free gift without
social obligations prevails only if we
already think of everything in market
terms and in a commercialized world the
idea of strengthening bonds through
giving and reciprocity may not be such a
bad thing wherever you may live
you